foreign
[Music]
Okay so we've done this once before
let's see how this goes let's see how
quickly we don't know what the topics
are
yeah if you wanted me to lay you up for
anything and you said no no let's just
tell a lot about karate oh wait you know
what here let's lead it with one of my
favorite I didn't even know that you
were doing this now live your bit about
Nancy Pelosi oh how you open your show
this is the quintessential Nick depalo
joke what about no and I go how many
people here are like me you hope Nancy
Pelosi's been using Roundup in her
garden for the last 20 years
it sounds Innocent but it's as hateful
As It Gets
you know I mean honestly God your next
question should be called Innocent but
hateful yes yes I'm gonna call it tough
love yeah don't steal that hateful
hateful but honest which is called the
hateful me and it's eight people but
with his face on it how about it's
called it's the Jews
how about Gibson already has the right
three letters how many words letters you
know what talk about it though when we
talk about cancer culture Gerald said
this the other day if Mel Gibson can get
the Jews to start funding his movies
again well that shows you how much money
he makes the juice
I may or may not have had a conversation
with him about that there's hope for us
I think I think what happened to him is
that he when he had his thing some of
the some of the the brass some of the
people that make Hollywood's great
movies had said come on we have a second
you got to take a seat for about 10
years yeah and 10 years to the day like
literally it's like hey you got you need
a timeout now some people get a time of
five minutes you got it for 10 years and
that's the way it is okay by the way and
by the way you're welcome yeah it sounds
about right actually those voicemails
let's see you're still worth money it
just you gotta wait a little bit more
okay hold on a second we'll develop it
while you're gone if you guys want to
see any of these people live
jimbrewer.com nicktip.com you can watch
him on Mud Club Brian Callan I don't
know this is one of the few times where
we pre-tape so I don't know if your show
is airing yet my show my show yeah I
don't know when this helps yeah yeah
Alexis right yeah Alex is every Friday
yeah yeah
from him every day like all right look
I'm not supposed to tell you this but I
just got these new papers these new
Panama papers you're like all right look
I'm I'm with the little ones I can't
well he gets information I don't know
where he gets his information but he was
saying Obama was gay forever ever so is
Joan Rivers really well she said that uh
Michelle Obama said uh Michelle they
said Michelle Obama she goes first any
first lady that's right right before she
went in right before she went and she
went um oh come on everyone knows
Michelle's a transgender yeah yeah
everyone knows and then the guy kind of
lazy because everybody knows yeah she
just moved on well that guy that gave
the press conference about it but that
wasn't made up about the crack and the
limo yeah I mean I don't know I can't
verify yeah but well cheese it was awful
dude
why would that affect your hearing yeah
what are you doing how are you wearing I
don't know what happens man
fire another boner no because I keep
because I'm screaming I'm not gay well
let's not take in the toilet already huh
fella all right hit the like button uh
or hit the rump smash the run button uh
leave your comments below topics you'd
like to hear I guess a murderer I cut
you guys off before I had to plug all of
you Josh
what do you have to say smash that oh no
I'm making you uncomfortable so violent
for crying out yeah what were you saying
I don't know how to touch the button you
were saying you cut us off before but
you were talking about something and
then I was well you brought up a topic I
was hoping it'd be karate but it wasn't
yeah well music because you're an
infected no he was talking about a Thigh
Master
karate you know the thing about karate
is my father will do that my father
would be like I was in Chile and I'm
like you don't speak Spanish so don't do
that how do they do that well I think
it's because they want everyone to know
how International they are yeah speaking
of which what do you think constitutes
uh I guess we can go with this racism in
comedy Nick you're up for the love of
God
I'll have you know I got a lot of black
fans yeah I haven't met any of them yet
I do Chris Rock told me Eddie Murphy
loves me uh you know I told you Jamie
Foxx they were watching me at uh oh yeah
I know Arsenio Hall's house it was in
Reddit actually uh what do you mean what
kind there's no such thing as racist
well you know because sometimes people
now they say like oh it's about who's
that you know you can't punch down and
so that's who says this by the way well
you know the comedian too you can't
stand hey people on Twitter no no
they're comments I love these I love
these little things they make up
like punching down I think like a
girl getting smacked in
the face by her father is hilarious and
so do you all I mean it depends on the
context no just smack her for no reason
over Dad's Shimp
put them up put them up whoa sneaky
um but she can't run in a circle
what constitute is racist well if it
comes out of a white guy's mouth and
it's about race period that's considered
racist today they don't want you talking
about it they don't want you discussing
it it's hilarious it's their domain
everyone I'm not talking about just
comedy that's in the world in general
but in comedy too like it used to be
obviously like blackface Minstrel shows
okay we all understand it unless you're
true but then it came out that oh no
wait a second you can't even do a black
guy's voice that's black voice and then
I was thinking I think every person here
has had a bit where you've described a
conversation or done a voice but my
experience on the road is is none of
that my experience on the road is you're
one thing from the
meat and then I'll be on the road and
and and if it's funny it goes and people
just want to laugh so I'll see sometimes
young people
uh though I'll see young people it'll be
a guy who brought his girlfriend
and the girls apartment on Thursdays
well I know that's that's well that's
they but but I'll see that and I'll go
and I'll see that she's not quite
getting it yeah because she's been you
know but then my comedy is what's called
Universal yeah right yeah like
myaccount.com guys a lot of physical
stuff yeah
let's not plug my dates but if you want
to that's me yeah wait until he brings
out the watermelon and mallet yeah I do
I do a Gallagher uh uh retrospection I
like his oversized couch because he
looks tiny on it
well that's one of the that's one of the
great bits I don't care what you guys
say but size differentials are funny if
handled properly yeah it does make
yourself I am a little self I I don't
really do racial stuff but I do a lot I
act out every character every voice sure
and a lot of times I'll do either an
Asian or something else and I in the
back of my head I'm going someone right
now is already tweeting how angry they
are and then I'm a racist and then the
other side goes I don't care yeah but
wouldn't you say that you like because
the intention but wouldn't you say the
exactly I know your intention are you
just being me
funny like I never tried to be a big
difference exactly like even making fun
of like somebody who's gay in the
audience remember when when that was an
acceptable Prejudice like you could just
make fun of gay people all day long but
I never for me I was always like they're
probably three or four people in the
room who are gay and having a good time
and I I don't feel like making them feel
bad if it's funny it's funny but yeah
that's all I don't know I just I
disagree yeah as opposed to Nick he
wants to ruin their bachelorette party
well you got to make one of them cry one
of them laugh
that's a perfect joke he bottles their
tears um but that's got to be tough
because you were talking about for
example like at the seller right which
is sort of your Premier Club and you've
said a lot of people yeah I mean the
story's legendary where you might just
go off on somebody
um but they tolerated it there not all
clubs do
think what do you mean when you say
tolerate well I mean the people are
understood they didn't punish me yes
yeah no Manny
who Lake Greg Manny who started the
comedy cell owned it he was a musician
himself so he sort of understood the
artist's point of view and yeah and he
really backed that free speech to and he
would come to my defense every time but
then he passed away and gnome took over
who's a great guy too he was like sort
of like his dad but Nom sat me down near
the end of it's probably 10 years eight
ten years ago and go look
we love the way you stick your thumb and
the eye of political correctness but now
you're making it hard on us they were
getting so much hate mail and I didn't
even argue with them I go I go no say no
more I go because I've left here some
nights
um not feeling good about what happened
yeah I feel seriously you do have a
conscience
what were you doing well I'd be doing
bits and then like a white Hood young
girls well remember this it's on the
campus of NYU oh sorry some you know a
handful of freshmen who didn't know who
I was would stand up you're just being
mean and then I'd call them filthy kids
and I hope you get cancer tonight and I
like that and uh
sometimes we line up in the back of the
room and watch Nick yes I bring friends
I'm like wait do you see you wouldn't it
and then you had filthy that's really
where I draw
that would but I'm just saying and I
didn't even argue with gnome because at
that point you know what happened with
the comedy so I was down there so many
nights in a row for 15 it feels like
it's your house yes and it's not they
paid to get in but they feel like you
feel like they're invading your space
right and you know you're gonna play by
my which is not the you know and I knew
I sort of knew that but then I'd have a
few drinks upstairs before I went on
right because I had to drive an hour and
a half fight traffic from Westchester so
I was Private to go yeah I'm trying to
drive back an hour and a half that's
right
I always respected I mean you were the
only guy doing I don't remember anyone I
think Colin would try a little bit not
like him though but Nick was the only
guy doing the stuff he does and it was I
don't want to say ahead of its time he
just he didn't care what the times were
and I really respected he never ever
changed or bent for anyone or any time
yeah and the worst the time Scott he
still was the same it looked like he was
more militant because
it made me look more you know uh
nefarious or whatever yeah but I just
but I didn't choose that's that's like
I'm just being myself right I'm sort of
the same on stage off state right right
it's sort of a so I just stayed the path
I didn't but it wasn't like I was choose
I didn't go out there I'm going to be
politically incorrect that's no because
you're going to take the hard path I was
going for funny yeah and people always
found my anger even in high school
um found my you know yeah
someone's angry so I just love laughing
at it it was indeed it was sort of in my
D.A I'm from a line of miserable Italian
Guys and so I think that goes back to we
were talking about in the last episode
back to Italy feminism like I think a
lot of people say oh you're being angry
as a man because your mat that's toxic
masculinity I do think there is the the
level of Truth to that is I do think as
a man getting angry about something you
it's sort of an expression of I can do
something about this because you can and
then be proactive or this month right
and you're gonna go do something whereas
when you're just being sad first off
it's not funny to just be said and
second sadness is almost just an
acceptance sometimes of circumstances so
sometimes in that anger phase you can
get off your ass and do something it's
like man I'm so pissed about this you
don't have to do that when you go um I'm
just sad you're depressed yeah and now
you have all these alt comics where it's
just it's sad right when you have Hannah
Gatsby come up self-deprecation is
actually self-humiliation and I won't do
that well then get off the stage yeah
yeah we're all humiliating ourselves
everyone is if you're on stage to some
degree right you're effectively feeling
yourself humility yeah I just think that
stand up was always a place I know it
was always a place where if you were
funny none of us gave it what you look
like or what you did like the only thing
that mattered when you were in those
clubs in the comic comic cell or comic
Cellar or a comic strip or stand in New
York wherever it was in New York
especially it was are you funny or are
you not and you weren't gonna you
weren't gonna get through those New York
crowds go to Pittsburgh and try your
esoteric comedy tell me how it works out
for you with a bunch of guys who work
for a living who are like and they get
stale as hats on make me laugh you can
say anything you want but you better be
funny and so so we'd see somebody it
didn't matter Wanda Sykes like would
show up and she was if she was funny we
weren't thinking she's a black woman and
she might be gay I didn't even thought
about that I was just like I know she's
fine she's getting up there and that's
and and there was a respect there and
then there was this weird fraternity
it's like we're a bunch of Misfits that
can do this really weird peculiar skill
which is I can get up on stage for an
hour no matter who they are and make
them laugh that takes a long long time
long time that's right so I don't so now
now we're now we're weird enough to be
doing this and working on that and
struggling through that and by the way
back then all we want to do is get on a
sitcom so we didn't have to do it right
it was such a grind how do you think the
industry changes though now because yes
it was always about who sold tickets but
now you have a lot of people who right
didn't start with stand up at all yeah
and they just show up and it's like oh
it's a one-man show and these clubs say
you know what it's better to have that
person in here than an actual comedian
because we know that they'll sell
tickets because they have an Instagram
following what do you think here's what
happened here's what well that's what it
is
right but here's what happens right they
they so you're a YouTuber you you what
happens is that works for about one tour
and then people get wise and they go I
didn't laugh it sucked because so you're
up there for an hour an hour 10 minutes
is so long if you don't have comedy
that's right I watched plenty of very
famous people get into stand up in their
40s 50s and they get up on stage 60s yep
and they get up on stage and oh my gosh
it would get quiet in five minutes it's
funny the audience may love out of
you if you don't bring it in five
minutes it gets Sagebrush a
dog's barking in the distance I mean
crickets it was it was like oh
performing at an outdoor Drive-In yeah
dude yeah yeah bro yeah you're right it
always lasts one tour yeah let's
remember back in the day who's what was
saved by the belt that was oh yeah
started touring Dustin Diamond and then
everyone would go see and like oh wow
that was Joe yeah
it just never a podcast that day so
podcast you had a podcast too you go a
bunch of actors trying to do and they're
like but you're not interesting because
they wouldn't even be a guest we'd have
guests on for a while we'd have like
podcasts or actors and it was like yeah
didn't you learn that from watching The
Tonight Show on Letterman for years yeah
five minutes and actresses came on but
it was five minutes so it worked right
but well no it didn't even know they
were about nothing you know I mean like
you said but I don't have a problem with
it no dude go ahead have your way have
your we've all been there go ahead and
knock yourself out right it doesn't it
doesn't
who cares as long as you keep prevailing
at what you're doing it's it's just they
don't bother me but it is depressing
you're on the road and
I go to walk to the club and it
literally across the street Mr Fluffy is
playing at a Stadium yeah
seriously with like a rubber duck hat it
would affect my first eight minutes on
stage
and it will be the biggest laughs I got
the whole night I just go off that flat
Mexican untalented and by the
way I met him is a very nice guy and I'm
just saying but people found that
refreshing
I mean what people people know what
they're getting after doing this 36
years finally yeah last 15 years people
come out to see me right so they know
it's coming yeah you know that's the
question do you think because sometimes
comedians will say oh that's the kiss of
death because now you have an audience
who's there to see you so that they'll
give you more grace and they'll laugh I
don't think that's necessarily true if
you approach it the right way you're
able to be more authentic to your voice
and not worry about that half that's
right you have to be alive up there
right I haven't even seen much of your
stand-up brown but I can tell you would
be funny for an hour yeah you have to be
alive and somehow you keep them off
balance yeah yeah I I like it's when my
fans go Jesus that was a little yeah you
know I mean I kind of feel like I'm
cooking yes I don't do it on purpose but
I'm just saying I'm riffing up that you
got to be alive but the formula might be
to make sure you never that you always
know you're not smarter than your
audience yeah it's a really important
thing as a comic to make sure that you
and I think that's the fundamental
difference between a lot of people on
the left who like you were going back to
what you were saying last episode which
was these people think they're smarter
than everybody else and I think if you
are out there the way we are where
you're touring and you're talking to
Real Americans you realize you don't
have anything over them I'm not smarter
than them I'm just not for the most part
I may know something over here but they
know something over that that's right so
there's a there's a there's there's that
that Democratic you know that democracy
that relationship where where I don't
know that to me is Texas state is a
benevolent dictatorship yeah
there is a lot of Mussolini in there no
I lost I lost some people pandemic and I
have to say it was nice losing them I
didn't want you felt you were more free
I don't I don't want I don't hang out
with people that don't come to the show
anymore and I don't want they're just
they're toxic yeah so that's a great
thing about what you're doing is now
they're coming to see you I had I was
very like hey I'm kind of like the the
nice happy guy which I am yeah but when
this all hit and I started listening
this is just what I'm talking about and
people like oh why don't you go back to
this and that and that I don't want them
yeah I don't want and it feels so much
better that really that's where Jim I
saw you like I've always been a huge fan
I I always think thought you were one of
the funniest people period and I've said
that he has a reputation during the
history is one of like the best
storytellers he just feel like oh best
storytelling I think he's one of the
best Comics I think he's one of the best
Comics period ever I think I just he
just cracks me up I mean everything he
did is always been funny to me but when
you started getting up during the
pandemic and you were posting those
things about what's important in life
and making that stand that was when I
was like this because you're risking
something yeah you didn't only come up
as a conservative commentator and say
I'm gonna go do this
kind of like well maybe I was assuming
that Jim from New York well like uh-oh
no no no not an officially I know what
you mean like a New Yorker more I should
say a little more to the left yeah like
you know I mean weed smoking
but I saw this Evolution when I'd start
reading articles about you and your dad
got sick and you had kids and I go this
guy and you were making a lot of sense
every time I heard you don't you think
you evolved a bit from like the day I
met you oh a thousand percent I think
everything changed to 2008 2008 is when
everything changed why because there was
one there was a woman that came uh we
were at a I was at a a pub in my town
it's like guys night out we'd you know a
bunch of dads and that night I went to
go order beer and she came up she went
oh you're the
you're like the drug guy you're the
you're the you're you're the you're like
really blue comedian and I went what and
I wanted to I said have you ever seen me
she wouldn't know but what it what it
made me realize is
what the world thinks of me from the
work and the stuff that I've done and
how I try to appease people
and then it was that moment on I'm like
I'm gonna just start being Who I Really
Am which is I'm a family guy I grew up
with morals I I do believe in a God I do
have I have morals I believe what's
right and wrong and this is who I really
am I'm a family guy I'm uh I look out
all for one one for all and that's when
I really made my divide and it was the
greatest freeing moment and that's with
my dad I want people to see that I with
my dad maybe it could help you take care
of your dad well whatever it is I
started thinking about that in terms of
like in at West Point I believe there's
a statue I don't know what the statue is
but at the base of it it says a nation
that finds itself
on the lines it's willing to fight for
yeah
yeah and also the statue of Lincoln
right next to it yeah
I thought to myself
um
like I was like that's kind of how you
should be as a human being like when you
have children you start to realize there
are lines you're willing to defend and I
mean really defend yeah and and that
that's where you start to realize this
game is for Keeps in some ways and if
the bad ideas win the day if enough of
them win the day we're in serious
trouble we can lose our Republic we were
talking about that on the show one day
where a lot of people say oh once you
have you know once you have kids you
become passive and I'm going I feel like
that's sort of a litmus test once you
have kids I feel like I've become way
more aggressive and protective when I'm
going this is something we have to
preserve detective about ideas too yeah
yeah but really like if you would not go
to in other words if you thought you
would go to extreme lengths for anything
before you now have a new sort of
visceral perspective of whatever it
takes to keep them alive to keep them
fed and protected I feel that way about
my poodle yeah that thing's aggressive
as hell yeah I think it'll take you take
out your Achilles so you hate people
that do that though that like I don't
have kids my doctor like my kids yeah
they compare them to I go how
insulting to it yeah
[Laughter]
oh God anybody who's against her husband
felt chinchilla I know
or the way they kill them ah it just
makes you feel god-like yeah they drown
them here's the reason let me finish
it's not Michael so quick
look at these large tanks
roll that clip do we have that clip yeah
the fair life milk farms
don't worry about it more whiskey please
your fingers broken you can't pour
yourself down I don't know man I like
having things done for me
not like a husband
that's true that is true this is one
thing I will say this uh we were talking
last time about feminism
and talking about relationships you know
men haven't really changed what they
want and this applies in relationships
but it applies in entertainment a lot
too men generally speaking still want to
laugh want to be able to Escape right
Sports comedy if you look at it
um women have have changed in a lot of
ways what they want in relationships as
well as what they want in content
um and and that's like for example I was
talking with a lot of the women who work
here we have unbelievably strong women
who work here I know people are
surprised but the showrunner is a woman
right you've spent time back there
um the issue there is is uh well there
are a few things you never get into an
argument I asked I would ask women this
I would say do you ever get into an
argument with your husband with your
boyfriend and uh are you afraid of him
retorting that you're sexist
said No never they go that's what men
are always afraid of in a relationship
if they request what they want in other
words right a lot of men are like man
it'll be nice to come home to a hot meal
what am I your Chef or be nice to come
home to Safe rep what am I you're mate
we hire those right
um and men they become more reclusive
they're afraid 40 something percent of
young men will never get married and
that goes back to feminism it's
destroyed relationships where men don't
want to get married and women say there
aren't men worth marrying it's because
men are afraid of I don't want to be
falsely accused of rape I don't want to
be accused of sexism but I still want a
woman who's nice who makes me feel
supported who takes care of me and I
have safe reference is they but is this
is this sort of I love the cyclical
nature of these things is are we looking
at sort of like so now sex is dangerous
right it comes with that guy gotta have
sex so you've got regret you could have
regret and then you know all of a sudden
now now I get me too and all that so a
lot of young men are like I'm not even
gonna do this I need I need an app I
need I need a video all this is the
I wonder if this is now sort of the far
left enforcing seeing those old pure
puritanical rules on sex that the right
the religious right had you know so
maybe it's just we're going back to
traditional ways of it's like this snake
eating its own it is no that's silly am
I being yeah
Nick you ever what's that song I'm I'm
just assuming see I'm getting brushes
because you're Italian what's happening
actually no what there's a song I was
just listening to it where I couldn't
believe the lyrics he's basically saying
he's telling the wife like uh wives
should be lovers when he comes home make
sure you're not in curlers
the song was about basically Tony
Bennett
was Tony Benetton well thank you is it
Tony Bennett so basically
song is
it's it's definitely
but what they're saying is Hey listen
ladies just because you're married
still when he comes home make him feel
important be look look good yeah
um you know it lift him up because when
he's gone he's playing the world beats
him down the world beats him down
there's other women at work and and he
does what he does but when he comes home
just because you're married or whatever
don't just sit there and and do you know
this don't take him for granted just
like a man shouldn't that's the case
exactly the one taking each other for
granted both sides but I have to say my
wife and I go through stuff like this
where
here I get there's someone in my family
who's like I can't believe that my
mother would cook for my dad and do
things for my dad and that era the women
then said my dad repeatedly so we can
get well she no no but she was talking
about her family oh okay oh okay okay
where where
my wife literally when she just says
things like thank you so much for all
you do and all the time you sacrificed
for our family that little tiny right
thing makes me like right here you know
what I feel important and because I am
out there doing and Gifts even though
she didn't mean it my wife even though
she didn't mean it she writing a book my
wife writes me my wife writes me little
love notes and just hides them somewhere
like she'll send me a love note like
it'll be I'll open up my book and it'll
be like I just want you to know how much
I appreciate you and you're so sexy when
you go I'm just like I'm the that's
all I need men men they're dancing in a
relationships
a little bit acknowledge
penmanship is horrendous it is her
grammar sucks you you don't know
calligraphy I'm gonna I'm Gonna Get You
handwriting lessons
um Papyrus my wife does that too and
Squid Ink she uses squid ink
she rents the boat and she's got a net
and she scares the squid uh until they
ink but man it makes a difference it
makes up and that's all I ask is that
you write me and then tie it to a
pigeon's leg and roast the
pigeon and that's all I'm asking for but
it's the same thing we're talking about
that in relationships where men still
want the same thing it's often it's very
I think that's a big reason for the
changing landscape and comedy you know
it used to just be we want to show up
and we want to laugh whether it's
offensive or not as long as it's still
funnier than it is offensive even back
in the day when people aren't used to
Blue humor and now that's changed where
a lot of people are going well I want to
hear what it is that you have to say
half the audience and it's like well I'm
you're here to say something funny yeah
and then what if you say something they
don't like and now you have a lot of
people who are booking shows I mean
there's people were shocked for example
at uh just a CMT where try that in a
small town right and they weren't going
to run it anymore I'm going why are you
surprised because you think the people
who run the country music what does the
T stand for country music something
television television Country Music
Television you you think that they're
like you the viewer it's a bunch of it's
a bunch of white women from Viacom yeah
correct they're totally disconnected and
they're going I know that people think
this is way too far we're going to ban
it and that's the disconnect it's people
in positions of power changing what they
want same thing out of that
entertainment relationship I I try to
explain to my my friends my sisters and
when I'd be watching something and I
always see the liberal streak in it yeah
and they get upset when you're imagining
it I go how can you say that I lived in
I'm in the business I've met these
people at auditions right I know I said
you don't know their politics who make
this you don't even I'm watching
the ID Network when they do these they
do these shows like American monster I
can love these shows but they're based
on a murder but it's not it's called
American monster this one or murder and
whatever it opens up the first thing you
establish it's a Christian family living
in Ohio they they but they do it they're
very slick about it they open on the
cross they make sure I'm going to church
and the guy's doing the voice it's just
typical American Suburban film and and
the whole underlying thing is look it's
not just black people who murder each
other that's that's the you know
what I would accept all of it all of it
if one Simply Safe commercial didn't
have a mustachioed white hipster the guy
robbing you no I know I just went by
from ring yes honestly just one yeah
just one they all look like the crime
statistics yeah they all look like
they're from the Second City improv it's
like oh yeah oh yeah I'm terrified of
having a cat burglar from Upright
Citizens Brigade The Barista from
Starbucks
yeah who'd I used to reference I don't
know uh and and Begley she's the one's
breaking into my house whitest
guy that could find it's every and I
just had we did this segment you know um
black and white and the gray issues
where I would just talk with people and
the guy goes you know we're negatively
portrayed he said you know black guy in
the media he's like crime I said hold on
a second I've never seen one commercial
like for a for a home alarm system where
there's a black guy goes well yeah
because you'd get in trouble if you did
that and then he realized as he said it
well wait a second wow I didn't even
believe what I'm saying and then we
found a lot of countless Common Ground I
love that you're doing that that's
that's my interactions and I think this
to his comedians right because there are
a lot of if you're a comic you're in a
green room if you're doing a if you're
at a place where doing a showcase set or
just for laughs at least 30 if not 40 of
the comics are probably black we've
talked about this a lot of them are
black they're they they tend to be great
Comedians and they tend to again they
come from a culture that encourages it
and so your interactions with a lot of
them are not reflective of how the media
messes
way more nuanced it's way more
conservative that's right a lot of black
like conservative go back to Patrice
Patrice Patrice if he was still alive he
would probably have been a full-blown I
mean he was veering right on a lot of
issues going I realized I was wrong on
these things and I've heard them say
that ever really no but admitted he was
wrong well later happens he even talked
about Radiohead Creep
this song white people love that
I'm a creep cause you're white
you're guilty as that's how they feel
but I'm trying to tell them you
shouldn't feel guilty just be proud
you're white but he would just talk
about creep and now white people love
that because they love the brow beat
themselves and that black people didn't
do that and he just really he was like
Tyrus does that on if I can bring up Gun
Hill so he's Kai Tyrus is biracial is he
yes I don't know he's just a giant is he
ever oh my God huge
um but he he he he does that he points
out he yells at the audience they have a
live audience there yeah he'll say why
are you guys getting quiet you know yeah
or whatever he'll he goes I can say it
from because I'm black or whatever but
he sees it from both and he does it if
Obama did a little bit about the if he
did a little of that when he was the
president instead of dividing us yeah
biracial he could have really healed the
racial Gap instead he exploited it I
think so you know remember Patrice so
even talking about Obama saying it
wasn't what wasn't what I thought it was
going to be yeah can I say this is
there's a little bit of a false bill of
goods I just think when you're funny
enough like Bill Burr had Bill Burr we
were I was at the comic store and Bill
Burr uh he's already done on a special
so I'm not giving the joke away but he
goes I'm pro-choice but I think abortion
is murder I mean you know it's like you
take it it's like taking a cake in an
oven and you know you pull it out before
it's ready and throw it on the floor I
mean you know it's it was still a cake I
mean he just had to give it a little
more time but at the same time I'm
pro-choice and everybody I will remember
him doing it at The Comedy Store in a
full house and everybody was like this
you could see people this is L.A and you
might see people in their 20s and things
going like this going
oh
[Music]
I hate to do this and I love Billy he's
as funny as anybody ever do it
um and yeah part of it he gets away
because it was funny yeah he's also
married to a black woman and everybody
knows that and that goes a long way in
Hollywood whoever mentions it
she's on his podcast now oh yeah pretty
regular yeah but you know I remember
that bit and uh but he kept I'm saying
it buys them a little Capital yeah I'm
not saying how would that bit go no I am
he's brilliant Billy Billy every
guy I grew up with he's hilarious I text
him every time I hear him on the radio I
go dude I want to kill you he's
absolutely hysterical but how would that
bit go if instead of saying like look
right I'm pro-choice but what if he just
said all right you know okay dude I'm
pro-life
right I I was wrong how would it Go
it'd be a disaster like you know people
it's like you know at least pro-life
they say Hey you know I'm putting the
batter I'm putting in the cookie sheet
they put and someone smacks it out of
their handling what was gonna be it was
gonna be a kid right it's better how
would it go if he said dude I'm pro-life
done done he has to couch it yeah and
that's and I'm not it doesn't he is
hilarious fun right but do we all agree
that that would that's a day that would
resonate very differently if you said
I'm pro-life yeah here's what's ironic
about me Mr right winger when it comes
to abortion and I even say this I go
look when I was younger I got a few
girls pregnant and I was glad they were
planned parenthoods or whatever the
I said back in the 80s you get them done
it like you can get them done anywhere
but Midas Muffler had a special on
Wednesday anything under five weeks you
get Kai's balance and new wipers
and but I would say this I said vacuum
while you wait I do that's what I said
they put the girl up on the lift they
bring out the dirt back oh boy
um
right now you're watching hit like
they're pro-life and they can laugh well
that listen but this is what I I couch
it with I'd be a hypocrite if I I took
girls when I was younger I was glad they
were planned parenthoods I would be a
hypocrite to go I'm pro-life right right
but I say this I go but the more I've
run into it now the reporting baby is at
nine months and and I I go now I I guess
you could call me pro-life because I
it's ridiculous it's extreme and I
followed up with like six other
brilliant abortion jokes that I probably
won't do here but save it for this genre
but for the special I'm done with
specials
seriously what the is a special
gonna do for me well I think we should
do we've talked about with Mud Club
putting together um there aren't many
people who could do this but a catalog
of Nick's best because he has what four
or five specials that are out there
doing one that's like an hour 45 of his
best stuff why don't we just do a
tour the with the four of us
indeed yes you be the draw that'd be a
monster I'd take the money monster that
would be a monster you know what I mean
I'm gonna go out there as a I don't want
to follow him I'll go up there's an
emcee and was it I'll make the audience
do the ducky ducky quack quack what's
that dude yeah
yeah quack quack what's the guy who
makes the like he has this joke one
night uh something ducky yeah and the
audience have to go ducky ducky quack
quack yeah you know what I'm talking
about black guy here's a comedian right
I'm not making this wait wait wait wait
wait there was a black comedian who
would go out and like but every time he
would hit a punch Chucky ducky Chucky
Chucky Chucky say something and the
audience
well that's like to get there was
another black comedian hamburger that's
right that's right we talked about it
hamburgers the other one I was just
gonna say hey
hamburger you know he's into it it was
very funny there's trademarks yeah yeah
yeah I had a friend of mine this is he
goes I can't even say it I'm
embarrassing I don't know why yeah he's
a bouncer bar he goes I'm thinking about
carrying a spoon around
and he goes yeah just like I have a
spoon like this and don't even like my
trademark who's this problem with that
is I can't be your friend anymore and
I'm not throwing a flying headlock right
now for suggesting it a spoon yeah
okay spoon do you have a top hat and a
a a cane with a cue ball on it
too well how about an eye patch you
here's the funny thing is you
think that you're you know you're
following that comedy world of
escalation none of that is as
embarrassing as a spoon here like an eye
patch would make sense hey hey guys I
gotta tell you Brian's always got that
spoon yeah yeah maybe would play the
spoons
what's the deal with airplane food am I
right
you hit it makes two different sounds
it's great dude hey um I I eat soup I'm
on a diet so I use a small
look hey everyone shut up I take the
spoon I put it in my mouth oh I
put this one in my mouth I was like I
guess it's funny
will you do want more of that he
died
it's a silly stuff Hey Okay so this
brings me to a question this is my hook
after we punch out I go
can't even do it I don't know how they
do the fart with the armpit I can't do I
get bench all this now
I got back we should do it now we're all
gonna come up with it after after we do
like a 10 minute set and we all come up
with a little let's do a tour favorite
Nations
how many times you heard that
is
the treaty what does that even mean Tour
all right what's the worst and by the
way hit the like button you can share if
you want to see more of the murder show
what's the worst gig you've ever done oh
this one
[Laughter]
the obvious answer I went I did the
worst game I ever did was it was my
buddy Dove David off of a great comic in
his own I like Dove yeah dub Dave off
one of the greats uh one of my closest
friends he said I got a gig yeah he goes
I got a gig it's some Jewish it's some
Jewish uh like Federation I don't know
what it was it was like a it was like
young Jewish uh lawyers of America I
don't know what it was but it was this
thing you repeat yourself yeah and so we
get there and I go I he didn't he didn't
do any due diligence uh we get there
it's a paid gig
and I'm looking around and we go
upstairs and it's just a bar but there's
a bar downstairs so there's a bar
upstairs on a platform and then there's
a bar downstairs and the bar downstairs
is crowded and people making noise and
talking but we're gonna do a show up
here and I go well they're not going to
hear us and a guy goes no we got a mic
and he pulls brings out a box that you
know on a subway it's called a speaker
oh no you got a speaker so he's got a
box
Mike I'm like what and now by the way I
go where's the stage he goes we don't
have a stage and I go but I'm I know but
I'm going to be here and we're in a bar
and there's a bar going there's a
there's a corporate party going
on downstairs oh God the only thing
missing is an accordion and a tuba so he
goes yeah well we'll just figure out if
you can talk loud on the mic I go loud
in the mic so I go all right but we
they're not going to see us so I'm gonna
be it's like doing a it's like standing
in a bar and doing stand-up in a crowded
bar with a crowded bar below us right so
I go this I'm in one of Dante's Rings
right now it's not gonna happen right so
I I go I go I need something and the guy
goes
oh hold on and he goes into a storage
closet and pulls out I'm not making this
up he pulls out a the kind you know the
couch that you buy for your dog it's a
little couch that your dog lies on it's
that it's it's a it's a dog couch yeah
and he goes can you stand on this that's
also horrible for your ankle stability
it's not good for your ankle stability
so I go can I stand on this so now I
stand on this and when I what do you
think I'm gonna think I'm kidding the
ceiling I had that much clearance on the
ceiling so now the ceiling is here and I
got this mic that I I can't move around
because the cord's not long enough and I
did stand up like that and I shattered
into this mic they didn't hear a
thing but to the to their credit they
listened and they laughed and then Dove
got up on that mic and we that that was
the worst cake I've ever
imagined all right hold on a second
we're going to continue this and hear
the rest of these hell gigs uh hit the
like button if you want to watch the
rest of this we're going to continue on
Mud Club Lotto scatter.com got Nick show
Brian show and uh I don't know comment
below if you want us to do a tour at
some point yeah I don't know hope well
you you comment but maybe we'll do it
maybe we won't but we all have to have
hooks we all have to have hooks it'll be
called the Captain Hook tour in my club
now there you go
foreign
[Applause]
it's very quick it's not even I want NYU
I did stand up with Steve Byrne and uh
and I and it was it was Asian mathematic
math grad students they were all getting
their math in their PHD or something in
math theoretical math and they were
Asian they didn't speak English I did 40
minutes on birds it was a bird it was
the theme was birds and uh and it was
the it was as quiet as a dead bird as a
bunch of Asian math students dead bird
it was as quiet as it did it was quite
as much Asian math students yeah yeah so
that was the other gig that I did that
made me want to quit do you have one
that sticks out Jim the worst case God
yeah this is it was a private gig that's
every I think everyone's gonna have an
answer for a private gate because
money was phenomenal yeah thank God so
it was I'll tell the kids the money a
lot easier to swallow a lot easier as
well now so my age goes hey uh it's it's
a private gig
um now we'll say it was that
Trump's place in Miami
he goes and I forgot the name of there
no no he's got another he's got a golf
course somewhere near Miami Airport I I
don't I think it's Trump Golf Course
yeah yeah
you don't know whatever it's called it's
not Mar-A-Lago it's another place a says
it's all he goes he goes uh it's all
real estate guys I want oh God I know
plenty of real estate guys they're fun
this is gonna be fun this is easy this
is an easy gig it tells me money I'm
like ah this is stealing money so I fly
to Miami as I'm checking in I'm looking
around there's a billion Hasidic Jews
like so
I go are they golfing like what are they
what are the gigs on Friday nights yeah
are they golfing here like what's going
on yeah that's why I've never seen a set
of Jews golfing good job for the UFC uh
292 price this is that racist and he
goes no no they're they're here for a
convention okay so it's during the day
and I go to the pool area and I go the
pool area
and all this issues everywhere
everywhere and
it was also gay there's gaze there's
guys with ARs everywhere I'm like what
the
was it the Federal Reserve yeah like
what the should I go what the
is going on
so I got I sit down to have lunch at the
bar area and I ordered like a chicken
sandwich and a guy comes up to me and he
goes uh hello my name's Saul what a
shocker and he goes he goes uh we're
very excited that you're playing tonight
and I went what do you mean and he goes
you're performing for us and I went
oh my God for all the Hasidic Jews I
thought I thought I was doing the real
estate he goes this is the real estate
he goes guys in a one piece all my life
then he goes they're the ones that own
everything in Manhattan Connecticut all
the big buildings
I'm just being honest it's just you can
look it up it's honest and I went they
they why and he all my life I'm not even
on my kids lives I'm not even
exaggerating nowhere why because he owns
the Chrysler Building or what I go
what's up with the ARs he goes there's
five billion dollars here and what
what and he said to me they're not going
to listen to you they're very rude this
is he goes I get very upset I love you
on Howard
um and this is so he goes we were gonna
we were gonna hire George Bush as a
speaker but no one's gonna listen so we
I'm a lot you can't even make this up so
we'd rather make this stuff back to you
that's great he goes so let's get Jim
Brewer oh my God at least they'll know
from how he goes they're not gonna
listen to you and they're very rude
don't be upset by it I'm like oh you
know and I'm like no I'm gonna crack
them I'm gonna crack them
well
I go in the room no when I say
nobody's pain they're on the phones
they're walking don't even acknowledge
my existence
plowed through 45 it was the most
horrible oh the guy gladly gave me the
money but that was that was not money it
was five billion dollars it wasn't you
know what a check for them it was this
thanks bro some new shoes they pay you
in a treasury note it was nice but yeah
wasn't I not allowed to say his City
Jews no of course you were mine was
similar I had two really bad ones but
one I ended up becoming friends with a
guy but one was a corporate gig it was
an Abilene at a Saturn dealership for
the Christmas party and they found me
off of Myspace but here's the thing the
reason it's so much worse it's like
yours except there's only about 60
people in the room yeah so it's in a
room behind the steakhouse like for
parties uh and the same thing they give
me like they don't even give me actually
uh they give me a microphone it's not
connected to anything
no stage I'm just in a room and they
want me to do the raffle and I'm with 60
people where the choice was a rib eye or
their Cordon blur chicken and I'm
sitting there and of course I'm bombing
everyone's drunk they don't want to pay
attention 500 by the way was the pay and
there's this one lady who did pay
attention but she took it upon herself
to go you're not funny what that's not
what we do here that's not funny and so
I treat her like a Heckler like you
would at the comedy Center
similar and uh then at that point the
guy walks up who's the owner of the
Saturn dealership he goes oh whoa whoa
whoa let's uh only get to the raffle huh
and he makes me after getting into it
with his feet
he makes me do the rap and I do the
raffle and she's just looking at me the
whole time and then he's like let's uh
let's try it again and I have to finish
20 more minutes of my set oh yeah for
500 at a Saturn dealership in Abilene
Texas you know you can say no to this
not then I was very poor then you don't
know
yeah no you don't know but what was
yours uh Nick that you can never had a
bad one
smooth sailing over here
not a confrontation nothing no problems
with the money people listen they left
can you think of one though that really
sticks out it well I've told it so many
times the one it's more about me bombing
than about like being a bad gig you know
I mean it was opening for um Paul Anka
at the Cape Cod Mallory outside I'm only
going to the business I know exactly
where it's at I've only been in the
business about two years
uh Cape Cod Melody tent the only reason
I got it is because a kid I played
football with knew somebody who works at
the oh that explains your frame and
you're still doing like the material I'm
doing this uh honest to God I say I was
raw but I'm probably more my language is
worse now than men I was trying to when
you're young you're trying to do TV
claims yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
so I I get down there a little early and
people are getting out out of their cars
and I'm I I'm not yeah I saw at least
three oxygen tanks
oh yeah taking them out of there I'm not
I'm not exaggerating and I went I must
be in the wrong parking lot this is like
a hospital or something there was nobody
over under 76. I am not I I I
knew Paul Anka you know had a few hits
in the 60s and he wrote The Tonight Show
Theme he's actually his catalog of
writing it's like Dolly Parton it's way
more than realizing absolutely so um
he's Lily white though you know and they
of course my friend didn't give a bit
about that and uh so I got and they go
oh by the way it's in the round and I go
what does that mean well the stage will
be rotating while you're standing on God
yeah oh my God I go watch yeah I'm up
there eating a Burger yeah for the
first six minutes it is when 2500 people
are quiet
I'm so nervous right I put my drink down
behind me and I forgot that I'm rotating
I go to reach for my drink and I see it
180 degrees away from me
my mouth is cotton I'm stumbling over my
words and just eating a big
burger they play you off so so so then I
went into the last five minutes I saved
it with uh depends jokes and old people
hitting themselves and Paul Anka was
Furious that I said so oh yeah and I
called my buddy I said do some research
when you have people I think you do it I
just imagine how that went like all
right you ungrateful should he put your
head on my show
I drink I like the Crowder in the middle
of your story goes Anchor's got actually
quite the cat box
incredible writer he knows yes it's not
what he's saying it's what he wrote All
you have to know
he wrote that tonight
I did he gets paid every time they play
they flew me down and do Tim Tebow's uh
annual uh
[Music]
he's got this charity and they flew me
down but it's all athletes and I'm like
I got athletes Hall of Fame athletes
College athletes and sports guests I'm
gonna crush this room I'm let's
go same thing yeah fly me down in like
Florida this golf course first class
everything let's go I'm gonna Crush no
joke I'm I'm I can't wait I can't wait I
got famous I could probably Tony Dorsett
I don't remember who it was but all
these famous like Hall of Famers so I'm
I'm a pig and I'm gonna kill this room
and I get there and there's a sort of a
press like red carpet and the first
thing I see is a child with the uh the
boys
and then I see another kid and I go
that's a nine-year-old but but wait this
Saturday's for sick children there goes
all your Ronald McDonald House jokes
cancer and I go number one I'm already
I'm already lost all my funny number two
I can't
damn There Goes My cleft palate
stuff and I'm fine bro I'm literally
like I I can't do any of my material and
I've got sick kids in the audience well
there's that child right there that
child right there and they're on they're
they've it's a heaven in Florida and I'm
seeing that you know and they don't have
and so all you're thinking about is your
heart your your that that takes all the
comedy out of me number one number two I
can't do my jokes and I tried to power
through some of them and I kind of use
different words the only person laughing
the only person but dying is Urban Meyer
like right over there going
down
come on
that doesn't matter
dude I've got that was I went to my
hotel room and I I stayed there I didn't
come out no no no and then I tell you
guys about my work I got a plan
oh I I guess you'd be I bombed in front
of like 40 000 people oh yeah I feel
real bad for you Jimmy what was the cut
at the door dude
wait a minute so this is like this is
the only fans this is the end of that
this is end SNL 98 I'm not really I'm
getting maybe five grand a gig which is
a lot at that time they turned around
like Hey listen Jay Moore can't do it
again
um here's the number and my eyes bulged
out of my hell the kids in them it was
it was it was money down for a 500 000
house and went oh my God and so they it
was huge money it's Gator growl like
I've never heard of this
if we get if you can get the footage of
this this is good it's probably one of
the greatest bombs in history if any
trying to find it exist I I don't know
but it's bro oh it's one of the greatest
Brewer bombs in the history of mankind
of anyone so it's me David tell and
that's got to be tough because you're
like you're very you go big or go
homework comedy right yes putting a lot
of yourself into it and for them to
reject that oh
well here's what happened yeah and
Daniel Tosh no one knows who Daniel Tosh
is not who he is yet okay so we get down
there like hey you know it's Cosby
before the rape it's Cosby Billy Graves
Billy Crystal it's all the wrong way and
they all been here we're honored to have
you no no gay jokes no cursing no
smoking or what I'm like I'm on
television no this is gonna be a piece
of cake but I'm looking at David Telco
and now there's no way he's gonna pull
this off gonna do that yeah how's he
gonna pull this off right you can't
swear right you can't swear you can't
smoke you can't say gay you can't say
that or no um Gator growl Gainesville
Gainesville Gainesville and they went so
I'm like I'm kind of like this is when I
get this gig then I'm gonna start
playing football Arenas like State like
I'm already I'm already sold out for the
next 10 years this is the biggest thing
in the world so Daniel Tosh goes up and
no one knows who he is at that time all
right so he's just a kid no one knows it
David tell goes up and again right
before he goes up they go no you gotta
sign the contract no if you if you do
any of this you're not getting paid
don't smoke uh don't smoke on stage
don't drink on stage and if you violate
any of that you don't get your check you
ain't getting your check and you have to
same thing correct oh sound like this
David tells gonna get his ex kicked so
David tell goes on stage and I'm like I
gotta watch this and he lights a
cigarette oh no and immediately like
what the is he and he goes let's
get this out of the way
sometimes I stick my a fish ball
just to let him know who's boss
he goes what is eggnog is it really just
Health
[Laughter]
he goes sorry Dean tonight's for the
students
he does 15 minutes he comes off the
stage he looks at me and he goes guess I
ain't getting paid
oh wait oh
hey how about those pigeons in New York
you know you know I'm married to this
wives are crazy huh hey you like a great
puppets
forty thousand people oh no no it's yeah
it's strong section and this section was
like we don't like this guy
and then this said she was like yeah we
don't like this got you so pull
these hands sections of going this
guy and then they're like no we like his
characters on SNL it was
did Dave get paid
was a telephone no but then Insomniac
but I learned a comedy lesson like he
didn't I don't ban for no but it was yep
right but there's also a flip side it's
like you also shouldn't take a corporate
game if that's the terms beforehand I
don't do it you know what I mean but no
I'm saying that's the terms
express your art you know what I mean
it's like if they say hey look these are
the terms then just don't show up but
that is a funny story oh my gosh if
that's on the internet I'm telling you
the greatest bombs in history
just to let him know his boss
oh my gosh
yeah he's sad his jokes he might be the
best joke writer ever I was traumatized
for like five years after that
oh I know they held the check man
Geraldo he did Villanova and they said
don't do any gay priest you know
increase molestation so I feel like with
you that's almost like even if you
weren't now you have to oh yeah yeah and
I did because I wasn't doing well for
the first few minutes where I went into
that and started murdering and not even
written jokes I was making about the top
of my head so it was really it's just
from trauma yeah and I see while I'm up
there I see the lady that you know said
hi to me and Greg and it brought us to
The Green Room I see her standing next
to Greg her face is red she's like in
his ear while I'm up there looking at me
and they're going
and then then I bring Geraldo up and you
know he comes up as I'm going off he
goes we're not going to get paid because
you
know it's funny they held the
check and uh we got it like a I don't
know probably a week and a half after
that but Geraldo wasn't mad at me a
little while you know so it's actually
it's uh I don't know if you've ever so I
have a friend who's really wealthy super
I don't wanna but he'll he'll know if
you're watching this hey okay thanks uh
he lets us use his plane every now and
then
is I got into a fist fight with his
lawyer after a corporate gig oh you on
the pump on the tarmac yeah yeah so I'm
going out there and it's uh he says like
oh Dean Kane's gonna be here and like oh
he does this huge corporate party every
year and uh I go oh okay so Dean Kane's
kind of a friend of the show I go oh so
he goes yeah you want to roast him a
little bit so I write 15 minutes of
roast jokes on Dean Kane that's not a
little bit yeah I know I didn't realize
that not everyone else was roasting Dean
King so I go out and like it's just like
you know like Dean Kane's so pretty that
when he was born his mother tried to
draw him in a bathtub and like that's
the first thing and Dean's sitting there
with of course two beautiful broads
laughing ass off
um and then uh but I'm on a stage it's
about 16 feet high and below me are the
again the ultimate the raffle prizes so
there's like Kenny Chesney tickets and a
bun and they're doing the raffle as I'm
performing and of course I start bombing
and I I don't know how I still can't
remember why this guy was so mad at me
later on I think he might have been a
Kenny Chesney fan that's the only thing
I can come to because he's probably his
husband so I make fun of exactly so I
make fun of Kenny Chesney I get divorce
for uh for uh fraud you know couldn't
find a reconcilable differences between
all the books in his mouth or whatever
it was something like that you know and
uh I hear like boo but I don't know who
it was it was one lone like almost like
a sketch I'm like okay so then we're
flying back on the sky's plane across
Texas and his lawyers on the flight and
it's just a long night me and Johnny Boy
are just tired and he's drunk and we
land is he's drunk his wife is drunk and
I hear hey I gotta take a pass just to
get off the planet okay great after you
um you know Madame and then we get off
the plane and Johnny boy goes hey nice
meeting you this guy I didn't realize he
was the guy's lawyer at the time who
hosted the entire corporate party uh he
goes you
to Johnny boyford and John was what he
all right he walks off and then I go hey
uh nice shirt and play with he goes
you you piece of just like that
like what I have no idea he goes yeah
you you start poking his finger in
my chest you piece of I still to
this day have no idea what he's mad very
good I think yeah yeah he's drunk I
think he was a Kenny Chesney fan that's
all I can come to or a piece and I go
okay look I don't know what's going he
goes and then my dad walks up he's like
hey look this is the first time you've
written on a private plane he's like hey
look this is a nice plane I turned to my
dad I hand him my jacket my cell phone
and a guy of one of the biggest knife
companies in the country happened to be
there that night gave me a really nice
switchblade and I give my dad a
switchblade I take it out of my pocket
he goes oh this is really and he looks
and I just double Palm shove the guy as
hard as I can across the tarmac I'm like
all right if we're gonna do this grab a
problem yeah and he comes back it stops
I immediately call the guy who owns the
company say look I'm really sorry I want
you to hear this from me I almost kicked
your lawyers at tarmac last night he
goes oh no he was drunk that's why I
sent him home on the plane you were
doing me a favor let me know anytime you
want to use it wow that's a good guy
yeah and he's still his lawyer you're
talking about he's still his lawyer but
because I have that's the way closest
I've come to almost kicking a grown
man's ass I still have no idea I think
he was a Kenny Chesney fan I think he
was the one guy going boo we're
always but no idea why he was so mad
guys like that but now I still occasion
another guy who hasn't been punched in
the face hasn't been placed in the face
that's right he got shoved though yeah
he got shoved he got double pumped yeah
you're sure he's punched in the face but
I don't know by the way you do know that
Kenny Chesney is a flaming homosexual I
have no clue I know he doesn't wear
shoes he's like Jimmy Buffett only
lesser than yeah
I didn't know this was going to be a
Kenny Chesney bashing uh faster that
wasn't the intent I heard that too yeah
it was Renee Zellweger she divorced him
and said uh was it false pretenses oh
exactly could have been a reconcile it
was like after four days so he's a
little guy
yeah like come on that's about it
yeah it's like Renee's Albert are like
nope she should have come in never
touched me he didn't touch it once what
you heard me what happened where
all right so you can't you can't tell
your worst kid you said you'll tell us
off air the actual one yeah I was
threatened by a mafioso oh geez really
scared the living that's all I can say
about it
um yeah I that's how my agent
sent me into a thing that he had didn't
research it was the scariest two days of
my life oh wow um I can tell this guy
because he doesn't want to tell the
story yeah
that's why I was threatened because I
told it on my podcast once oh really
when I was in my basement you know yeah
yeah the next day I was talking about
the gig and I got a message why I I
that's all I got to say about this is
not like a little I'm like no yeah
[Laughter]
I said if you're coming after me you
hang up is there anything I can do is
there anything I can do to get out of it
he goes he goes if I was coming for you
you could be at the bottom of the ocean
I'm getting oh whatever do and it
doesn't matter how long it takes me but
if I got if I get the contract you're
going I don't know I guess maybe and
you're going to the bottom of the ocean
yeah anyways but if you're already there
I guess they must have some kind of
re-breathing Technology oh man you
missed the whole point wow
bro I'm talking about the mafia in New
York
you could be a no no well come on
don't worry I truly believe that Pesci
was part of the uh uh like listen oh I
have stories listen when he came when he
came on SNL like you took him and by the
way
people don't realize that the mafia is
Big with a lot of things even Major
League Baseball I've talked with some uh
MLB guys and I've heard stories where
I'm like what oh yeah how does the
public not know this
um but in Hollywood too where there's
many gangs uh just whatever it's too
late now so
she's coming on SNL I think I'm gonna be
in the next I I've told the story before
but
I to this day even if I see him believe
he's connected somehow because he comes
on SNL and I I and he's coming to do a
sketch of me and I'm I think I'm going
to be in all the Good Fellas movies
because I grew up with all these guys
and you did the pressure impressed yes
but I grew up where I grew up all these
guys existed so uh I didn't really know
I knew of them but I knew about whatever
so when when I walked in that room
he had dude he had his he he was dressed
like straight out of Goodfellas and the
first thing he asked me he said are you
Italian
I said no I'm not tired and he said then
where do you get off using words like
guinea and on television and I
just and I and I
I said well I got you know I got an
Italian guy to help me write this thing
and he goes yeah I talked to Frank I
already talked oh God and he goes uh he
goes that Frank Sebastian I already
talked to him he goes um but here's the
deal no one gives a about writers
they only care about it's out of your
mouth that it come no one cares about a
writer you're the performer you're the
one that whose mouth that comes out of
and he goes off on how his father came
here and helped build the country and
you portray me as an animal and this
went on for like 10 minutes and I swear
to God and I already knew about him and
the Jersey Boys like the you know the
play Jersey Boys and all I already knew
that I already knew about that I'm like
oh my God I'm gonna have to pay Joe
Pesci 10 15 of my money the rest of my
life and I it finally ended with me
basically saying listen I'm a fan I
never meant to insult you this was I I I
just this is all just time we'll never
do I'm never doing this again never ever
doing this again and he turned around I
was like whoa what the I'm busting
your balls really on my life but when
he's joking around but when he's set I'm
telling you
that's great but I'm telling you the way
he did it here the way he did it that's
so good the way he did it he got oh no
he got it was the good folks but I'm
telling you my grandfather not until he
honestly felt my emotion and thought I
wasn't yeah
is that's when he's like yeah I'm
busting his boss but he wasn't possible
you don't think he was my grandfather my
grandfather was from best scared of
Spencer's Brooklyn 100 Sicilian he would
say things like this during the Balkans
War when in survey goes he goes these
people are animals the Italians are the
only people in the world that don't kill
indiscriminately these people are
killing the kids they're killing the
kids you would never see an Italian do
that in the history
here we go here's the program and that
was the way it is that was the way it is
but at the end of the day in an Italian
household at least where I'm from yes
Sicilians the men are always in charge
we're respectful but the man yes is
always we're the boss who's the boss are
you the bus that's it Jimmy did you tell
me
um because I know you do a great passing
that somebody told me a story a kid was
looking for a used car in the paper
and he sees one with somewhere in Queens
and he goes and it was peshi's house no
that's not me was it you I think your
dreams no I didn't dream I had
Mafia in my family and I finished my
story well it's not his
fish it's happening it doesn't existence
okay so who was it so the kid goes he's
in the driveway looking at the car
impressed she just comes out just like
you would hey you gotta buy my car
oh my God
yeah
that was so funny I just you're probably
right it sounds like
um he if he didn't mean it to you he's
given that speech yeah right I did it
it's a jab he's stealing you out yeah I
did I did a little
minor film
um and Bruno Kirby was on the film and
Bruno comes up to me gives me the one of
these answers oh the disrespectful
hancha is that what what is that
handshake it's kind of like it's a weird
how do you know the difference between a
Joe Pesci and Bruno Kirby impression
right because again it's very hard and
Bruno Kirby
God Rest his soul looked at me and he's
like
what was Joe like when he met you
and it I I
if you ask me that I would go oh you
know Joe was like this when Bruno Kirby
asked me that I went like what the
like what do you mean by that hey what
was he like when he met you I went oh he
did this and he just went
um
really yeah all right that's just
convincing yeah that reinforces my we
had a we had a show in Montreal a lot of
people don't realize this Montreal was
the place that all the drugs came
through no yeah
I would like to apologize
yes the first season is great the second
season sucks I liked all of it but
anyway so so this is so we had a show in
Canada before the before The Sopranos it
was called omerta all right and it was a
show about the mob and my my mom she
lived with this guy I guess he's my
third cousin my mom was close with him
named Tony Conte was in there he was in
the show so picture a guy being in The
Sopranos playing a playing a mobster
yeah uh running drugs for them and I
remember him you know at the all of the
funerals we had like when my grandfather
died he was close with the family uh and
then it turned out he was running drugs
for the mob in Montreal at the ports and
then he was put in prison guy in my
family yeah this show of America yeah
and that was real life I mean people
don't realize how thick the mob is in
Montreal yeah all Montreal you guys
anywhere there's a point yeah what's the
series with uh someone out there can it
was blood it had the word Blood Simple
something blood it was not blood money
with take from Sons of Anarchy it was
about the ports in Montreal and how the
mob was really drugs came through
Montreal because what yeah Bad Blood Bad
Blood that first season was and it was
really true I mean the biker War gangs
that we had in Montreal yeah I didn't
know anything about Hell's Angels
earthquake uh when we would be on I'd be
on the South Shore because people don't
realize they weren't just like Outlaws
they would run all the yeah and all the
drugs and they were organized they were
real bikers all ports yeah in the entire
world are run by all I shouldn't say
this acidic but it's all are run by the
Hasidic shoes
it's all I'm asking questions but that's
literally asking questions but that's
where you'll find yeah yes all organized
whether it's bikers uh mobster
traffickers whatever it is all ports
yeah are the places well the bikers
where you'll find it all so the mob is
in Italy the best one I can imagine yeah
but they're the mob is looking to make
money right it's a business whereas
bikers they're looking to sustain their
lifestyle being the one percent Outlaws
and Montreal was switched where the
bikers were basically they were so thick
with the mob
um there was actually there was the
Hell's Angels and then there was a rival
but they didn't even have motorcycles
called The Rock machine and they start
up like we have to be a biker gang and
compete with the Hell's Angels like we
don't have any motorcycles so again
Yamahas and and uh yes exactly and
then we would we would feel them like
they blew up ponies they blew up I think
it was because there's a language uh
barrier there's a language uh war going
on there they blew up like Second Cup
Cafe because they had an English name
and they weren't following the language
laws La Liga is a language police it was
seriously violent in Montreal we would
feel and we didn't get earthquakes it
was it would be the bikers blowing up a
clubhouse
I did a a
a mobster movie wasn't wasn't a big
movie but when we were filming we filmed
in Montreal and there were bikers
everywhere there were there were certain
bikers everywhere I'm like what's what's
and the guy's like yeah they're just
making sure everything's all right I'm
like yeah
what's going on like yeah it just it
really opened my eyes to like wow okay
who who runs things on on Johnny Boy out
there his dad can tell you a story when
he looked out of his office there was
just a dead body in the parking lot
remember remember on 4th Street when the
Hell's Angels had their chapter there in
New York City remember that they'd be at
McSorley's and places like that and you
just go by and you'd see those Hells
Angels there was a bar called The Edge
and they would hang out there because
their their Clubhouse was right there
and you'd see these dudes these Hells
Angels like the real dudes oh no that's
the real guys six four they handsome
they look like just and you'd be as a
Young Man you'd be like yeah I wouldn't
even talk to him and I was like I kind
of want to look like that I kind of want
to let you they were these these just
Outlaws yes
hold on these guys are criminals yeah no
no criminals but as an image when I did
Oz they would hang out on the because
oh I share a room with Chuck Zito I
should that's right that's what I was
going to ask you describing yeah and
they would just be sitting there and
they were always really cool but they
were just these
giant dudes and I'd just be like God I'm
such a I'm sorry but they'd be stories
about that and down in their basement at
that Hell's Angels chapter you hit my
buddy who knew knew them he'd be like
they're too wild boar down there right
now I'd be like what yeah they got a
couple wild boars then they got a hyena
apparently I'm sorry if you're in the
Hell's Angels and I'm making the story
up but this is what I heard these are
these terms for like new no no
hyenas so they had a real hyena down
there and they got out they got a a
fighting dog like a a pit bull that was
a champion like you know that Within
These fight rings and they tried to
fight the hyena
let's get the pit bull and the hyena
together and apparently the hyena just
like hyena was like oh is that what
you're gonna do you're gonna send that
man-made dog at me that's cool and
apparently the dog's going there came
right at it and the hyenas went and bit
it right through the head the fight was
over that quick yeah
all right there you go I'm passing by
you know but um but I remember that just
one I remember just being on set and
seeing those guys and being in proximity
with those guys always nice and I never
forgot my girlfriend
um I I come out of a bar and there's
this six foot four
blonde Hells Angels we get that they're
good talking Brian I know I'm a gay man
and then he was chatting her up he was
chatting her up you step right in it and
I sure didn't Nick I sure didn't and
give me two steps never forgot this I
she doesn't know this I found myself I I
went ah I gotta go back inside and take
a piss I didn't know I didn't know what
to do because I wanted to talk to the
guy but I also didn't want to but I
didn't want to with this game and
uh you know and so I'm not a man is the
point I'm making and I'm gay all right
we'll leave it on that note because you
have to pee clearly has to be shaking
his leg he's Michael J fox who's first
nickdip.com briancallen.com
jimbrewer.com and uh hey I appreciate
all you guys this is fun second time
four years from now yeah exactly let's
go on a tour I have a mortgage yeah
after you recovered all right thank you
guys if you want more of this and if you
want us to entertain the idea of a tour
Dear Dad be a monster that'd be a lot of
fun 15 minutes each yeah yeah we'll do
it'll be a showcase you're joining guys
for my big
we'll see I'm trying to send us off love
you bye remember none of this is
possible without you join the fight and
sign up for mug club today at louder
with kreider.com for 89 annually join
the fight at louder with credit.com Mud
Club today